I thought I was taking too many supplements, so I decided to take the astro clear, aerobic
clear, and so for a time, three times a day every day, and by osteopath and other osteopaths,
recommendations, and other vitamins every other day.
Do you see any downside for this?
So this person, I know the person who asked this question and they are doing fantastic, but
with their cancer, you could say they are in complete remission.
So I am all together and favor of doing this, this would be called Paul Seed.
So Paul Seed, your supplements, is that you are taking some time off.
Maybe you take them five days a week and off on the weekends or you can do it every other
day.
Just like this, I think that would be fine, especially if you are in a good position health-wise
to do some Paul Seed.
Are there any vitamins you would recommend that must be taken daily instead of every other
day?
I think you are making the right decision, and I think we talked about this on a call.
These are things that you are taking to reduce bad astrojones.
So that would be something that you do want to take on a daily basis.
Other things you could separate out.
But I think you might want to take on a daily basis are in the summertime, if you are sweating
a lot, you might want to stay on minerals.
Things that you could pulse very easily would be your fat-soluble vitamins, your A and E and
D and K. Those are things that store well in your body.
Water-soluble, nutritional things tend to not store well.
Is that maybe you would want to take on a daily basis?
You might make a decision based upon core morbidities, let's say I may have inflammation so you
want to stay on anti-inflammatories, the flavonoids on a daily basis.
That I wouldn't suggest Paul Seed doing this on somebody that is not going to clean bill
of health and doing great, so stay to your protocol at that point.